[Music]
matt
is with us in san antonio hi matt
welcome to the dave ramsey show
[Music]
hi thank you dave and thank you christy
for uh taking my
my call sure what's up so um
the question is well a little background
i guess beforehand
uh my wife and i were on baby step two
we have about 35k left household income
right around 100.
with uh buying back my military time i
work for the federal government
currently
with uh that equals about 12 i have
about nine years left and i could retire
from that um
my i also own a business that i opened
in 2016
and i do that part-time obviously after
the government work so my question is
actually transitioning from a government
job
to running my own business full-time
um i don't know
if i want to finish out the nine years
mainly because of the work environment
itself
i guess we could say politics behind it
and then also
the commute's kind of pretty rough it's
about an hour both ways
um so with that
how much uh money should we have set
aside before
before making that transition and then
what
what is what other you know what are the
best practices or best steps to kind of
make that transition as smooth as
possible what's your business
dog training oh okay best job in the
world
what uh what is it what is it bringing
in right now
annually uh annually
it brings in right around 30
30 to 35 thousand dollars
yes okay what do you make of the
government
i make uh 70. okay so your wife does not
work outside the home
yes sir what do you need to live on
uh right now we're living on about
well i guess like around like 75-ish
75-80
oh and you're in baby step two right you
said you you've got some debt yeah yes
yes ma'am
that's right well i'll tell you i'll
tell you what's so
great about this uh side gig generation
starting a side hustle is you have an
opportunity
to grow this thing small and it's i mean
it's already doing well 30 000 a year
i think is what you said um you have the
opportunity to grow this thing
while still having the stability of your
full-time job
now one of the things that we tell
people all the time is you want to build
this thing up on the side
so much that it can support you now
because you're in baby step two
you know everything's bonus because
you're gonna pay off your debt faster
um but you're building this thing up so
that it can support you you don't want
to make this
huge terrifying leap where you just hope
the business will support you now the
great news is you're
you know you're doing great like you're
already making a good stable amount of
money there
but i would continue to build this up to
where you're getting it to some of those
numbers you're talking about that you
need to live on
and then what's so great is it's the
next logical step it's not a terrifying
leap
um whenever you leave the government job
but if i'm you
you know matt i don't i don't want to do
something i don't want to do with the
bad commute for nine more years
i don't i want to really pour my life
into this business
to where it can make 70 100 or plus
get yourself out of debt and then you're
doing something you love to do
um you know full-time but it's one of
those things where you want to make sure
the money is actually there you don't
just hope it's going to be there
you want to build that business up so
much that it can support you
whenever you're ready to make that
transition yeah what christy and i
always say when we're talking with
small business owners and side hustle
folks is get the boat close enough to
the dock
so that you can step into it not leap
and hope you hit it yeah
and that's uh so what amounts to is
you're you're on your way yeah
so in in your case i think uh if i were
in your shoes
i would set a goal that sounded like
this when i have
three months in a row of
forty five hundred dollars or more
and i feel confident that that's going
to continue
that puts you in the high fifty thousand
dollar up to close to sixty thousand
dollars
be fifty five thousand dollars a year
okay which is less than
you're making now but so you didn't pull
the boat all the way to the dock you
weren't making 75 when you gave up a 70.
you don't need to do that but go ahead
and have a really troublesome year
because all you do is work
between your day job and the dog job
it's gonna feel like you're working two
full-time jobs because you are
yeah for a season yeah for a season to
get through but let me ask you this dave
so is your job seasonal matt is it
do you have like real dog training i
don't know is it like way busier in the
summer and like falls way off in the
winter
to be to be uh honest with you like the
whole 14 to 16 hour days is yes it's
getting long
i actually am able to take off
uh the month of july to spend it with my
kids and then also uh
december so that's like they're not even
working those
those two months yeah well i i don't
want you to do this on a wing and a
prayer i want you to prove it to
yourself
and so if i were in your shoes i would
want three consecutive months or 4 500
and i really don't care if you're tired
when okay because you're not gonna do
this for very long
what we're trying to do what we're
trying to do is escape the drudgery of
the day job
but we don't want to do it in such a way
that we run out of the haunted house and
get hit by a car
right but i guess what i was trying to
bring up with the seasonal thing though
is i don't want you to base your
decision on three consecutive months or
4 500
in a really busy season and you've got a
really slow season coming up because
it's not indicative of what
you can expect we want you to plan based
on what you can expect
right but what he's saying is the only
reason he made it seasonal is because he
just took the time off yeah yeah
so one july and one december but you
know if i'm in your shoes i don't care
you pick the four months or the three
months i want to prove to myself
and my wife that i've my family my kids
that we can eat off this thing
and you're not there yet 35 000 doesn't
do it for me you're going to take a pay
cut of 65
i don't think so to go from 100 to 35. i
don't think that's a good plan
but i but i would take that 36 you're
already making 3 000 man
i mean let's get that up 1500 more let's
increase that
and and prove to yourself some level of
stability
and then give your notice and go live
your dream
and then have a plan for training dog
trainers
so that you have a whole school going
and you're making 300 grand not
150. i was going to say 1500 i mean
that's just one dog
you have a dog for a month it's about
1500 to have if they go send them off
you know
yes about 12 1500 at least here in
nashville it's up to two thousand
dollars you send a dog
for a month they stay with the trainer
for the month they come home trained
asked ayo he did something similar
so that's why ao pays all kinds of stuff
for stuff like that
get you one dog matt get your one dog
one more dog one more
dog that's all you're one dog away man
if you're charging right
if you're charging right that's a whole
nother subject if you're charging right
that is so great yeah i was on a
pheasant hunt and that guy's
he trains up 15 or 20 dogs and takes
them yes
on the pheasant hunt and sells them off
and so he'll sell all those dogs for
i don't know you selling them for
anywhere from five to 15 grand a dog
but he had poured into him like that i
didn't have any idea what they charged
to do that those dogs could climb a tree
though they were unbelievable they did
everything
yeah they were amazing so well for busy
people that don't have time to train
them or take them once a week to
training they're like just send them off
bring them back when they're trained
wow wow can you do that with kids
i've got three candidates i've got three
candidates in my household i'd like to
send off if that's the case please
christmas is over all the fun's over
let's we're back to work
help me out oh
2 000 i'm so cheap i've never trained a
dog so i mean i've trained them but i
haven't
i haven't paid anybody to do it so i
didn't i've had dogs smarter than me but
that's a low bar
so oh my gosh yeah i think you're one
dog away per month per month
yeah so i that's what i would do if i
were in your shoes matt i want to
get the boat a little closer to the dock
you're jumping and i'm afraid you're
going to get one leg wet or you may miss
the boat completely i don't want you to
uh and so i want this thing to be a
thing where you did it without with
wisdom
uh without a ton of stress and you're
gonna be a little tired
between now and then but by the way when
you start a business you're always a
little tired i had two years of 16 hour
days and this puppy
before i hardly even made a living out
of it and uh that's a few years back i
don't want to do it again
but i'm not afraid of hard work and i
haven't not done what i'm telling you to
do i have done it it's a season
it's a season it's not forever and i
worked like i was unemployed this
i mean i worked like i was doing it
again during covet try to keep
everything running
i was back in here again for a month and
a half two months at 16 hours so
just whatever you have to do to run a
business that's what you do
but usually those are ebb and flow it's
not forever it's for a period of time
to get there